now that the transfer window is over I
can spend more time pursuing my hobbies
you know like playing football is this
like an artsy French film or something
uh eats match film oh nice I love
football movies jd's wanna know what's
good my man of course sickles I got mad
tankers and I've got over a hundred
million IG followers like well so I
gotta do it to be like he's ridiculous
you're so dull could anyone not like you
know what the hell I wanted to throw you
all a surprise party you know just show
how much I don't want him playing with
y'all France
we can't party we have a match tomorrow
okay never stopped me before
[Music]
and that was PSG demonstrating white
teamwork is important
Neymar we know you don't want to be here
that's ridiculous man you guys are like
brothers to me
and believe me I really love my sibling
oh wow look everybody and Bobby brought
the world of the prodigy so good so yeah
I mean yeah so yeah when he woke up he's
good still doesn't want to push cus I
love Paris a Germany in fact I love psg
so much that I got a giant PSG tattoo on
my back you got a giant piss Jeter
wonder back yeah bro hey there he is
look at what's good my man okay fine you
guys want to see it no problemo
I just need to you need to get this
shirt off because it can be a bit a bit
complicated
you're fine fine I know your shield
Cavani okay ready check this out blue
what the hell is that this is a new low
Neymar okay
do you know what you guys are meaner
than the PSG ultras man Jerry events are
Grapher to need to build your brand and
to get great press Lucas got to take
advantage of that and we're here to show
him how everyone on PSG is like so
judgmental I need to go somewhere where
I can clear my head yeah we should go
somewhere you can kiss your head like a
Pisa
Joe man who are these Bobo's that's my
wife and my kids Lucas a family man and
I respect that
I just want to expand his family to
include a few influencer models and
maybe an American rapper
it's like all anyone cares about these
days is like dedication and loyalty and
like sacrifice you know that corny [ __ ]
times are changing man I just here for
the money Neymar he's been murdered
what might be an Emer tell me about your
family
well I'm very close to them in fact like
that is my agent oh no way my wife is my
agent do you have a wife no actually but
I have a beautiful sister home very
close with really I would love to meet
her maybe we can all take a yacht trip
together someday
yo yo dope Neymar is not dead he is
merely play-acting all to avoid small
talk miss hurricane and I would have
gotten away with it too if it weren't
for you pesky Germans and your technical
quality I shall
[Music]